so let me show you a pseudo-random
number oh by the way just to give you
some examples you know we said we said
dice add coins for this that's a bit
pedestrian right in reality people who
use true random generator you can go to
well I think it's random Dorgan I think
is a website which does which time this
it uses far more sophisticated and
exotic kinds of physical phenomena to
users for example it uses a radioactive
decay so if you've got like a
radioactive particle and it's setting
off you know bits of energy it's losing
bits of fast right are the quantity at
which it does that and the frequency
with which it does it is sort of
predictable but it's not really
predictable right it's it's quite random
the other cool thing that they use
atmospheric noise so what they've got is
uh they've got some microphone pointed
at the sky and it's listening to sound
and that's pretty pretty random it's
about as random as weather right now we
can predict weather kind of three days
in a row but as anyone knows when
they've sort of relied on a weather
report and it hasn't come to I that's
you know it's it's it's not super liable
because of the randomness of it
all right so the pseudo-random number
generator I'm going to teach you today
pretty simple it's called the LCG or I'm
giving you the acronym because the full
name is a bit of awkward it's a the
linear congruent sure generator
LCG is a bit better right alright so I'm
going to give you the formula that that
makes this work the mathematical
mechanism that sort of turns the wheels
and uh it's pretty simple actually but
it's it's quite powerful okay so here's
the way the formula works and you'll see
hopefully you'll see why the name is
what it is so how does the LCG work let
me explain it by means of the name okay
so what we're going to do is generate
random numbers each called X right so
there will be the first X the second X
the third x a whole bunch of them
however many you want however many
random numbers you want okay so this is
what we call a recursive generator okay
or a recurrence relation so you guys
know how Fibonacci works right so a
Fibonacci number the nth Fibonacci
number is equal to the previous two
added together right so the nth
Fibonacci number is the previous one
plus the one before that and that gives
you you see this formula relies on
itself it's self referential okay so
that's what recursion means and this is
the same okay
so if I want to know what the next
number is you take the previous number
you multiply it by some number you add
something and then you take you do the
remainder thing where we're looking at a
modular arithmetic right so you can see
where the name comes from
Linnea comes from the a right it's a
linear function right in a very crude
way of think about it this is MX plus B
this is a straight line okay but it's
congruent sure because this R is much of
a fitting thing right it's the idea of
numbers being congruent to one another
okay so for example this example I'm
going to give is um the modulus thing is
is five okay so we're dividing by five
so soon and seven in this scheme are
congruent right they're the same number
really they're both going to reduce that
to okay so this idea of congruence is
really a frame to the fact that it's
using modular arithmetic so you need
some conditions you've got these three
numbers here they've all got to be less
than whatever you want to take
of okay all the values have the positive
integers that's fine X naught that's a
subscript not an index okay is the seen
number it's what you start with it's
just starting point okay so here our our
building blocks here's an example okay I
messed up with one as my seed number and
then I just kind of picked some numbers
at random I picked them all very small
so that we can follow the maps but just
like with prime numbers right this whole
process gets more and more effective
than larger our numbers are all right so
let's give this a go let's start
crunching through it okay we've got our
first random number here what's not
really random we chose earth okay so how
do I get the next one x1 what's it going
to be equal to well you go a times X
naught the previous one so that's going
to be two times one you're going to add
this constant C per constant and then
you're going to score more funny so far
so good
so let's work this out 2 plus 3 is 5 so
this is 5 1 5 so to do this mod bit you
say well what's the remainder after I
divide by 5 and the answer is 0 good so
x1 our first real random number is 0 now
how do we get the next one
x2 ok you repeat the process we can do
this probably be a bit quicker company
ok to tire 0 plus 3 is 3 and when you
take mine 500m star into 5 on time so
this is just going to be 3
I just went you we knew it was going to
have these properties ok what's going to
matter is the numbers that come out
there now I look at X 3
okay what's going to happen I'm going to
go 2 times 2 times 3 which is 6 plus 3
which is 9 so I've got to go 9 mod 5
which is 4 okay so another four and
we'll do the fourth one ok 4 times 2
which is 8 plus 3 that's 11 mod 5
now I take the remainder after I divide
by five as many times I can I decide by
five once or you take away five you get
six you can take away again now I've got
one okay now what has happened I've
returned to one which was my seed number
here okay so you can see why it's
periodic okay now by the way semi codes
dentally I hit that the period of five
after going to the fourth number why was
it the fourth number do you think wait
wait why did I hit after like seven or
eight or nine can you see this is kind
of like my limiting factor right because
no matter what I remember I get out here
I'm gonna get I'm gonna get zero one two
three or four
I can't get anything higher because I'm
going to go mod five on whatever result
I get right so I'm circling around zero
one two three four in some kind of order
now do you have a look at the order what
number what order if we ended up with
we've got one zero one three and then
four
so I actually skip down on to starting
one I'll never get to add this because
now that I've got two four I'll get back
to one so I'll go one two three four one
zero three four and this is like there's
some randomness to this right like you
could have come up with a random series
of numbers and this could have been here
okay so it has that uniform distribution
nature to it okay but it has these
problems you can see now this is what we
this is what we did right we just had
the same numbers we had x 2 adding 3 and
then taking your modulus of 5 is my I
put it in red because this is my seed
number this is what I started with what
you got here are one of the prime which
prime number of magic first second third
fourth fifth six and sure enough here
the same results that we just got one
zero three four one two three four no no
no no so I want to show you well if i
graph those okay you can clearly see the
period picture of what's happening right
there is one zero three four one zero
three four and it's happening over
again okay now the great thing about
doing this buying computer is that I can
adjust these dynamically right rather
than crunch through all the numbers of
things for a lot of it
so for instance if I change let's cheat
a single number okay let's just change
the modulus what we're dividing by
finding window so if I change it to 6
okay what do you get now what happens
hmm this is worse than what we had
before I wonder if you can work out why
look I'm only going 1/5 1/5 1/5 I keep
[ __ ] back and forth doesn't look good
well it's good guy who's trying I'm like
707 is a bit more your school it's
better when you sure what did you think
why is 7i more useful number it seems ok
guy straight hey it's a it's a bag what
happened 8 I like to 8 right I get 5 and
then what happens
I go 5 times 2 which is 10 then I have 3
which is 13 and then I take away 8 which
lands me back on 5 so you kind of
automatic option by choice right let's
go to 9
I can now I'm signing it something more
interesting now as the number gets
bigger you can see that these numbers
are getting really because I've got more
numbers to choose from I can get a 0 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 before I have to come back
to all real of so that's looking better
what if I go 10 why I go 11 now just
hold on many undo that yeah I just
changed a single number neither changed
by one tense okay but 11 is much better
why would 11 be better so much better
than 10
I got 12 okay think about this
10 okay 11 good 12 awful why is 12 so
bad it's a silly factors but not only is
it not prime it's very very not prime
okay see you see you see how prime
numbers and what is it today I don't
keep going let's up let's skip forward a
little bit a little bit I'm gonna go on
to a hundred how do I get a hundred Oh
now remember I said we're play with
pretty small numbers for a computer a
hundred is still a very small number but
it looks pretty good doesn't it right
now watch what happens if I just go up
just go up 101 it's very different isn't
it if I go up again now you see what we
talked about when we say random right
every time I go up you're getting quite
drastically different ups by the way you
might have noticed as I went through all
I do them you can see it in a row even
though this part sees to be changing
quite a lot this part doesn't watch it
again go back 1 2 3
why is that bit so consistent I know
because I think the numbers I'm getting
slowly up to the original good ok so
remember this is the linear
complementary generator right so this
thing over here is kind of mimicking
what a linear function is doing is I
know it doesn't look like it because
there's there's that adding of a
clustered right but it's growing a
linear rate until it hits somewhere
where when you multiply the next one it
goes over the threshold ok and the
modulus kind of kicks in and then it
started to get really interesting
axle hat closes for prime a bit both
better as you can see right it's not
completely it's not really random I mean
if you knew these numbers you get
exactly the same thing out but it's
random enough right if I gave you look
at these look at these numbers if I gave
you this list of numbers you didn't see
the graph okay
1 5 13 2961 if we play that kind of game
where it's like you know you get one of
these quizzes guess the next number in
the sequence right you're gonna know
what's the difference there he was there
and then it's gonna be like 51 before
what just happen it should hope so it
has enough randomness to it to actually
use damage it's gonna be a bit tricky
when you think about module Susan like
boy let's look I don't know as you see
what happens 3.1415 it was you can put
the symbol in it what's happening there
so there you go random number generators
they're kind of like a lost piece of the
puzzle when it comes to cryptography